while we're recording so
um I believe you owe me a video I owe
you a video yep I did make a promise
that I would record a video on log Jam I
didn't I forgot and then there's Log Jam
as well I don't know did we do a video
on log Jam if we didn't I'll do a video
on logger and here we are we're going to
do it we're going to talk about Log Jam
um better late than never Log Jam is an
attack from 2015 but it's a bit of a
classic I suppose in sort of a
cryptography uh world I think and it's a
really really interesting one
Log Jam is a really interesting attack
because it actually has a number of
parts right so the first part is that
you have to do a man in the middle
attack on an exchange right and then you
have to do a protocol downgrade to
convince a server possibly to use a weak
diffie-hellman key and then you have to
break it using a number field sieve and
after you've done that it you're all
better off you've got in you've got all
of the traffic from then on so if we
look at a very very high level overview
of how a TLS session works you have
someone over here which is called the
client and someone over here called the
server and this happens every time you
go to a website so you go to any online
shop that's hopefully encrypted this
will happen when you start so the first
thing is the client sends over something
called a client hello and this says I
can do all of these algorithms here's a
random number things like this the
algorithms that they send are usually
pretty good because browsers are not
stupidly programmed right so you know
they'll say I can do RSA I can do DS DSA
but in terms of encryption I can use AES
I could use Char Char
and at some point during this hello
they'll also say I can use
diffie-hellman or I can use a thermal
diffie-hellman or more recently I can
use elliptic curved if your helmet so
what happens here is they would send a
message that says something like I can
do Diffie Hellman ephemeral right now
remember this is from 2015
diffie-hellman ephemeral is no longer
used we usually use elliptic curved if
you heldman right and actually one of
the reasons is this attack you know
aside from the fact that it's getting a
bit old anyway now what we do as an
attacker so I'm going to get my
malicious purple pen is we intercept
this as our man in the middle so we're a
man in the middle here
and we can read and manipulate any of
these messages maybe we're sitting on a
motor something like this we say no no
we're not having that right we rewrite
this message to contain diffie-hellman
ephemeral export now for those of you
old enough to know export grade security
was the rules that the US government put
in place in the 90s to limit the spread
of powerful encryption so DHE export is
a 512-bit diffie-hellman key exchange
now that would not be considered strong
enough it was still considered not
absolutely terrible in 2015 except for
the attacks that we talk about in a bit
with the number field sieve so the
server then sees this client Hello
message and goes well this is a bit odd
this client only supports DHE export but
I suppose you know it's not an absolute
disaster we'll go with that
and so the server then sends back a
server hello and then a number of other
messages including their half of the
diffie-hellman key exchange so they send
a public large prime number P the
generator G they send G to the B mod P
and and various other things and they
also compute a digital signature and
that the whole TLS handshake is quite
complicated but they send a very weak
prime number of only 512 bits because
that's what the client asked them to do
now they can't actually ask them to send
a much better one but the client gets
this message and thinks well it's 512
bits it's not terrible all right and
they then go okay so it's 512 bits so
I'll generate my part of the message and
so on we continue like this is the man
in the middle just just listening to all
this the man in the middle is listening
in editing messages where they want but
they don't need to edit these messages
yet all they've done is they've changed
the first message to pretend that the
client only accepts or can understand
export grade weakened security and the
service kind of gone with it and at this
point nothing really changes the client
never sees that the server downgraded
their encryption and certainly in TLS
1.2 that's the case they just noticed
that the the P looks a bit small but
yeah right you know we we'll move on
right so if I continue this and at the
end they send two messages one from the
client called finished and one from the
server also called finished now those
are very important because these
messages have a summary of both of these
sets of messages and the reason that
exists is because if they didn't if
something like this could happen right
if a client has sent DHE but the server
received DHE export so their two orders
of events
are different right so theoretically you
shouldn't be able to do this but here's
the problem if you can break this key
exchange at this point here
then you can falsify this finished
message and essentially cancel this and
send a different finished message that
backs up your version that backs up your
version of events so the client then
thinks that the server saw very well but
it was meant to be DHE not export but
just sent a rubbish the export key for
some other reason fair enough right so
the question then becomes how do we
break a diffie-hellman key exchange in
what is you know fractions of a second
right well the first thing is you can't
break it in fractions of a second so
what you need to do is you need to buy
yourself some time in here so what you
do is to stop a timer happening you can
wait for a little bit of time the
server's just busy handling other
requests or something he's very slow the
server for some reason is on a really
weak 3G Mobile connection or something
like this so this takes a long time to
come through what happens is the man in
the middle will send some kind of TLS
alerts or other heartbeat messages that
kind of keep this connection alive for a
little while and that'll buy you maybe a
minute or minute and a half
and then what you do is you use a number
field sieve to break this diffie-hellman
key exchange and you have about a minute
to do it at which point you can
recompute the shared secret and you can
falsify the finished message and then
you can read everything from then on
right and that is a really really big
problem for any internet communication
and this is true this is a TLS
connection but this is essentially the
same for the internet key exchange
that's used in vpns as part of ipsec as
well so there's numerous
protocols that could be weakened if you
could break this so how do we break it
log Jam is an attack on diffie-hellman
key exchange basically and usually
diffie-hellman key exchange what happens
during let's say a TLS which is https uh
session or an internet key exchange
which happens maybe at the beginning of
a VPN or something like this so you know
it's quite important on the internet for
making sure that we get secret keys that
we can use to communicate I mean the
board attack is based on this idea if
you use something called the number
field sieve to break a diffie-hellman
key exchange but you can pre-compute a
lot of the work ahead of time and that
allows you to do a much quicker attack
so we should say live
so let's think about what diffie-hellman
is very briefly and how we could attack
it we talked about Diffie Helm before
with the colors yes and we also did a
bit of the maths as well but the answer
is basically you have a function called
G to the a b mod P now p is a very very
large prime number A and B are secret
numbers for Alice and Bob no and G is
your generator which is public as well
at the beginning of a session you would
agree on a g and you would agree on a p
now the reason this is hard to break is
because you can't take this or any of
the other values so for example you also
see as an attacker G to the a mod P we
can't take this value that's been sent
out in the clear on the internet and
find out what a was which we could then
use with Bob's public value to create
this this secret or we could use Bob's
little B value to create a secret
finding out what a is
is cool with discrete logarithm problem
and it's thought to at least be very
very difficult that's the idea and there
are variants of this problem but crop up
and cryptography all over the place so
for example there's an elliptic curve
equivalent now the interesting thing
about logjam is a strategy for breaking
this right if you could break this then
what you could do is you could man in
the middle attack something like TLS
and basically recompute the secret key
they're going to use to encrypt the rest
of the session and read everything in
the session which you could imagine if
you were for example a nation-state
doing some sniffing would be quite a
helpful thing to do so how would you do
this well doing this via brute force or
some other method there are various
albums that make this a bit easier but
none of them make it trivially easy the
best album we know is the number field
sieve now I don't really know how number
field sieve works I don't tend to worry
about it too much it's fairly
complicated but the important thing to
know about the number field sieve is it
has four stages right there's polynomial
selection there's sieving there's linear
algebra and then finally there's descent
that's all I know about it right now the
important thing though is that you can
do various amounts of polynomial
selection of sieving and you can do more
or less and it will make your later bits
harder or easier or bigger or smaller
and that means that you can pre-compute
some of this and then solve it later
much more quickly right key to this is
that these first three stages only
require the prime P that means you can
pre-prepare all of this based on this
Prime ahead of time right on the
assumption that maybe this
diffie-hellman will be using this Prime
what you end up with is a giant table of
data basically a giant Matrix or data
that comes out of these three sections
that represents essentially
most of the break finally doing a center
stage just keep the letters the same so
using a and the generator G right so
let's assume for a minute that you and I
were going to do a diffie-hellman what
would happen was we would agree on a g
and a p that we were going to use and
then we'd produce our private A and B
values and we do the diffie-hellman
if we knew ahead of time that this was
the P we were going to choose then you
could pre-compute all this
and then just do this quite quickly for
a short diffie-hellman key pair maybe
we're talking about a week for this and
a minute for this right for a much
longer key pair we might be talking
about a few minutes for this and a year
for this on an incredibly expensive
server but within reach of you know
really well financed attackers exactly
how the number Filter Works is not
really important actually what's
important is that we can pre-compute a
load of this attack so that we can run
the actual attack on Divi Helman very
very quickly almost live right when we
see an attack and that helps us do
something called a man in the middle
when we see a TLS session startup or a
key exchange at the beginning of let's
say a VPN so how do we link together
well if we go back to our diffie-hellman
key exchange the problem is that the
initial three stages of the number field
Steve use p and p has only been sent by
the server here but the really
interesting thing is everyone always
just uses the same P because there's no
real added security of using a different
one every time and in fact act using the
wrong one can lead to other attacks that
are also a big problem so in fact it's
actually pretty good practice to use
similar ones every time for DHE export
great security right Apache had one
built in right so an Apache web server
would use the same Prime every time 512
bits if it was convinced to use DHE
export so we given that we knew that
Apache would do this
we would just pre-compute the first
three stages of a number field sieve
we'd wait for this message and then
while we were keeping this alive we
would break this using the last descent
stage of the number field sieve which is
not trivial you need a lot of cores but
you can do it within a minute minute and
a half
at this point you can break the whole
the whole
um algorithm on its own this is already
an interesting paper but there's a
there's another half to this paper which
is perhaps even more interesting because
actually you can't convince every server
to use export grade security
even in 2015 90 of servers would say no
no we're not using a 512-bit
diffie-hellmaki thank you we'll use 768
or we'll use 1024 right now that is much
harder to beat
so the rest of this
paper asks could you beat it though
right not with a laptop is the answer to
that but how much would it cost and what
would the different four stages of a
number field look like what kind of
server would you need if you were going
to do this for a thousand twenty four
bit Prime there's two questions really
one is you know are most 1024-bit
diffie-hellman key exchange is using a
similar Prime which means you could
pre-compute half of the work or 99 of
the work using the number field see if
the answer is yes right and then given
that how long would it take a server to
do this and would anyone even bother
right that's what's really interesting
about this
so let's answer the first question the
answer is yes loads and loads at this
time loads and loads of
um https servers and many many vpns
about 80 or 90 of vpns were all using
Oakley group two now Oakley group two
the group corresponds to the group of
numbers modulo this Prime the prime is 2
to the 1024
minus two to the to the nine that's not
right 960.
right minus one plus two to the 64.
Times by
2 to the 8 9 4 times by pi I know it's
ridiculous plus 1 2 9 0 9 3. that is a
ridiculous prime number and it has a
generator of two all right so that's p
and that's G now why this has been
determined like this is not of any real
significance but essentially this is
what we call a safe Prime
um and perhaps that's for a different
video but
the point was that many many internet
sessions particularly on vpns were using
this exact Prime at this time because
why wouldn't it was a safe Prime it's a
good one it's defined in an IFC IFC
which I've got the IFC here it's RFC
um
and that was me thinking that you
remembered all that you know oh yeah I
know everyone thinks I can just reel off
Oakley group two no no it's the internet
key exchange RFC which is defined in RFC
2409 right now it's essentially a
standard and there's a few other primes
there's maybe two or three that most
things were using but huge amounts of
vpns particularly we're using this so
then big question becomes Okay so we've
got this Prime we know that lots of
people are using it we know we can
pre-compute
most of the attack
by using this Prime only and then when
the actual key exchange happens we can
try and do the last bit
um how plausible is that well in this
paper they calculate roughly how much
computational power you would need
to do this right to pre-compute The
Descent stage to pre-compute all the
three stages and then do the Descent
stage and they think somewhere around
100 million dollars of a server in the
Edward Snowden leagues there was a lot
of information about
various sort of secret things that were
decrypting quite a lot of internet
traffic and at the time everyone looked
at this and went well you know
it doesn't seem plausible you would you
would decrypt this amount of traffic
right but this paper makes a lot more
sense of those documents because it
suddenly makes you think well actually a
nation state and I'm not particularly
single in the NSA out here right any
nation state with sufficient budget
these are thousand bit diffie-hellman
key exchanges are now in reach because
they could pre-compute the number field
save and then they could just do The
Descent stage so what would happen in
practice is you would have a bulk
sniffing of huge amounts of internet
traffic you'd identify VPN data and
you'd send the key exchange off to some
massive server to do The Descent and
work out what was going on while you do
this man in the middle attack or you
wouldn't even do the man in the middle
attack you just because maybe you're not
trying to actually inject yourself into
the conversation and change all the
packets all you want to do is read them
so you just bulk collect data bulk break
keys and then bulk read all the
information and analyze it later right
um and so it's plausible you know as a
export grade at 512 bits you could do it
with a powerful server for sort of seven
six eight bits you could do it you know
with a very decent cluster of computers
but you know sort of a university level
could organization could afford it and
then for the Thousand bit Keys like
Oakley group two
you would need nation-state level
resources but it's doable this paper was
released and obviously they went through
proper disclosure but every single
browser immediately blocked any export
grade encryption Oakley group 2 was no
longer used almost immediately and on
anything
um and we now use 2000 bit
diffie-hellman Keys just like that
because that's how big a problem this is
you know even if no one was doing this
even if the changes in budget and stone
leaks were completely unrelated had
something else to do had to do with
something else
you've still got this kind of what if
though question of
it's theoretically possible I always
think it's really interesting when you
know a paper comes out and says this
could be a problem and then you sort of
find evidence that actually might
already be a problem uh which I think is
really interesting now in practice we've
moved on a few years it's not been that
long actually since 2015 I'm getting a
bit old
um but since then we don't use
modular arithmetic to do diffie-hellman
anymore we use elliptic curves and we've
talked about that one of the reasons is
that the number field sieve in this form
doesn't work on elliptic curves right so
there are various attacks on modular
arithmetic groups but don't work on
electric curve groups which is why
elliptic curves can get away with
smaller keys and makes them more
efficient
so TLS 1.2 had this vulnerability TLS
1.3 doesn't support these kinds of
diffie-hellman and also they added in
countermeasures in TLS 1.3 to deal with
protocol downgrade attacks where you
kind of sneakily change a client hello
to say something else the server reports
back but that's happened in a way that's
very hard for an attacker to avoid
so this had a huge impact and changed
the algorithms we used on the internet
and TLS handshakes and all of these
predefined constants because of just how
serious a problem this is right even
though a thousand bits at that time was
seen as to be totally out of reach of
anyone so really interesting story
so it's sort of a robustness now what's
happened is the app has gone in cropped
the image down to a much smaller one
which takes up less space in memory so
like kind of engineeringly type things
this one is getting creating removing
providing criticizing so like for some
reason these types of words